new xbox pre-orders were just as messy
as ps5s
call of duty season 6 has been revealed
and also monster hunter and resident
evil will be at tokyo game show
i'm chasity and you've reached your save
state for tuesday let's jump in
so much like the ps5 or rtx 3080 the
xbox series x and s pre-orders this
morning were
a mess microsoft tried to beat the bots
by telling people exactly when
pre-orders were going live
but that resulted in everyone going to
retailers at once and bogging down the
websites
some retailers like gamestop put you in
a queue but some people found a way to
skip the line in another browser
neither best buy nor amazon were
actually available at the designated
time
this was at least slightly better than
the ps5 pre-order since people had
advance notice and were ready for it
but still it was a total crapshoot
whether or not you were able to get a
series x or
s were you able to pre-order an xbox
series x or s
what was your experience like let me
know in the comments
next up we got a season six cinematic
trailer for call of duty modern warfare
and war zone
the trailer reveals two new operators
farrah and nikolai both from modern
warfare's campaign the two of them are
shown powering up a train station
underground before the video shows a
tunnel system that loops around the
warzone map
season 6 begins next tuesday september
29th and stay tuned because we'll have a
lot more info on the new season on
gamespot soon
and finally we'll be getting more
monster hunter and resident evil at
tokyo game show
tgs is starting soon airing completely
online from september 24th to 27th
capcom will be showing off monster
hunter rise monster hunter stories two
wings of ruin and resident evil village
monster hunter rise and stories 2 will
be shown on stream on saturday at 5 50
a.m pacific time and 8 50 a.m eastern
time
rise is coming to switch on march 26
2021 stories 2 comes to switch next
summer
resident evil village will be on stream
on sunday at 5 40 a.m pacific 8 40 a.m
eastern
village will be out sometime next year
on ps5 xbox series x and s
and pc those streams are definitely not
the most convenient for the west coast
and i will be fast asleep but luckily
you and i can go to gamespot right after
the streams to find out what we missed
and that's your save save for tuesday
i'm chastity and you can find me on
twitter at chasity underscore v
come back tomorrow for more news and
i'll see you next time
you